Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Decent. I'm your host as always Ricard Loops.
And today I'm joined by Doctor Joshua Nobi. He
is Professor of Philosophy and Linguistics and Psychology at Yale
University. A lot of his recent research has been
concerned with the impact of people's moral judgments on their
intuitions about questions that might initially appear to be entirely
independent of morality. But as we're going to talk
about today, apparently they are not. So Josh
, welcome to the show. It's a pleasure to
everyone. Thanks Ricardo. It's really good to be
here. So I would like to start by asking
you about experimental philosophy. So what is experimental philosophy
? Really? And how does it differ from,
let's say armchair philosophy? Yeah. Awesome question.
So experimental philosophy is the field that started around 20
years ago in the beginning of the 21st century.
And it's a field that really is the merger of
two different things. So on one hand, it
uses these methods that are the methods we see all
the time in psychology. So we run experiments that
very much look like psychology experiments and use the same
statistics, the same kinds of experimental designs that you
see all the time in the field of psychology.
But at a kind of theoretical level, it's really
very closely connected to philosophy. So there's this tradition
in philosophy, going back thousands of years of thinking
about, for example, thought experiments where if you
open up some work from Plato, you'll see him
thinking. OK, let's talk about the concept of
justice. Um Now consider this case, would you
say that's justice? Now, what about this,
this justice and gradually trying to understand what justice is
by considering thought experiments of that type. So experimental
philosophy is a field that kind of merges those two
things. So it's a field that's drawing on this
very long tradition within philosophy of trying to understand these
concepts using this particular kind of approach to understanding them
and the methods that we see in psychology of just
running systematic experiments, analyzing them using data and so
forth. So what you see in an experimental philosophy
study is something that might look a little bit like
what Plato is doing in some sense except for that
instead of um just seeing well, consider this case
surely. In that case, people would say this
, it's we say consider this, we recruited 1000
participants, they were randomly assigned to conditions in a
three by two design. We analyzed what their responses
were and we can see that people's responses are affected
by these factors. Now we're trying to develop a
deeper understanding of what's going on within people's minds that
shapes those judgments, what's going on in human cognition
that makes them have the judgments they do. But
how does it differ from science? I mean,
if in terms of methodology, it seems so similar
to what we see across several different sciences, then
why isn't it uh also science? Why is it
still philosophy? That's a great question. And I
think that the answer is that we should all think
less about that. So if you, if you
look at what's actually happening with this field of the
experimental philosphy experimental philosophy studies are just being published in
the same journals that or every other cognitive science um
kind of paper is being published in. So for
example, the journal Cognition, which is one of
the leading journals in the field of cognitive science,
a quantitative study of where experimental philosophy papers get published
, showed that one of the most common places to
publish them is cognition. And when you send a
paper to cognition, they don't do some special philosophy
way of thinking about it. They're just thinking about
it as a contribution to cognitive science. So it's
not as though there's some kind of sharp divide that
we really want to say we are not scientists,
we're philosophers and the things we're doing are not contributions
to science, they are contributions to philosophy, which
is something separate. But although there's no sharp divide
like that, I really feel like there is an
important difference that there really is something different about what's
going on. So if you think about, for
example, this field that's at the intersection of psychology
and economics in which people are trying to study what's
going on in people's minds that affects their economic decision
making. And there are people working in that field
who are psychologists and there are people working in that
field who are economists. I mean, it's not
like there are two separate fields. I mean,
there is a field of studying this but still there's
a difference that when an economist studies those questions,
it's different than when a psychologist studies, those questions
that economists are drawing this whole theoretical tradition that they
, when they were um grad students, they were
like studying real analysis and like um microeconomic theory and
and then they're bringing to bear that whole tradition on
these questions. I mean, you think about what's
going on in experimental philosophy, I feel like you
see something really similar that it it might not be
a rigid dichotomy between what we're doing and what people
outside of philosophy are doing. But there's something really
clear if you open up one of these papers,
you can tell it's written by a philosopher that it's
drawing on this kind of really rich theoretical tradition that
all of us in philosophy have been steeped in from
our undergraduate to graduate school through all of the um
interactions we're having now in philosophy departments and the research
we're doing is really coming out of that, that
we've been thinking about Aristotle for decades. And the
study we're doing is very much influenced by that whole
tradition, right? But I mean, I guess
that this also puts into perspective, the relationship between
science and philosophy because in many ways there, there's
not and uh there's uh there should, there should
necessarily be a strict division between the, let's say
two fields of knowledge. I mean, historically speaking
, of course, science even derived from philosophy.
But nowadays, even when people try to make a
strict division and say that philosophy is from the humanities
, and then we have the sciences which are two
separate things. Uh It doesn't have to be like
that, right? We I really strongly agree that
a lot of times experimental philosophy is presented as something
new as the it's kind of rebelling against the tradition
of philosophy. But I completely agree with what you
just said, it should be seen instead as something
old that if you look at um what was going
on in the 19th century in philosophy. When you
think about these figures like Karl Marx Friedrich, Nietzsche
Jon Stewart Mill, these people were very concerned with
empirical questions, questions about what human beings are really
like. And then they were trying to explore all
those empirical questions using all the methods that were available
at that time to explore those questions and then there
was kind of this new fangled revolution against all of
that, that people start to say all that stuff
that people traditionally did in philosophy. That's not even
philosophy, that's just science, philosophy. Is this
other thing that you can do from your armchair without
even um engaging with empirical data. And I think
that that revolution against the traditional way of doing philosophy
was just totally mistaken. There was never anything wrong
with the traditional way of doing philosophy, that what
those people were doing in the 19th century was just
totally right. And we should just go back.
It was the exactly the right approach that we should
have this met mode of inquiry where we're not um
distinguishing really strictly between these different things. We're trying
to go after these questions with all the methods at
our disposal. And we're exploring questions that are kind
of recognizably philosophical. But we're exploring those questions by
engaging with all the empirical data we can get that
will help us answer them. So after that introduction
, let's get into some of the topics you explore
in your work. So first of all, what
is belief, what is belief? But in the
work that we've done on this topic, what we're
concerned with is how ordinary people figure out what other
people believe. So, um there's something in our
minds that allows us to figure out what other people
believe about. So if I um am uh thinking
about another person, I might think. Um Even
though I'm right here in my office, she doesn't
know that she thinks that I'm at home. So
she believes that I'm at home. I know a
question arises like, uh about how to understand the
concept how people think about. So, here's what
we thought about that. Here's what we argue for
, with regard to that question that are more basic
way of that human beings make sense of why other
people do the things they do is not in terms
of what they believe in terms of what they know
. So the normal way of thinking about things is
that I would just think, ok, you know
, I'm right now, I'm in my office.
Does she know that or not? And that way
of thinking about things, thinking about what other people
know is something that's really fundamental and so fundamental that
it's very much shared with our other, with other
primates and presumably with our common ancestor, with those
other primates and something that's just totally automatic. It
, it as soon as you see someone else and
you're seeing like what they're looking at and what they're
not looking at, you immediately are aware of which
things they know and which things they don't know.
And then the suggestion we had is that this ability
that human beings have to think that other people could
believe something that's not true. That should be seen
as this fancy extra ability like something that only human
beings have, other primates don't have it. So
this suggestion, we're making a sort of a reversal
of the way cognitive scientists have often thought about this
. The cognitive scientists have often thought the most basic
aspect of how we make sense of other people's minds
is by thinking about what they believe and what they
want. And then we're suggesting, no, it's
the most basic way of thinking about it is in
terms of what people know and what they want and
then what they believe is when you're doing that you're
doing, like, just a very sophisticated thing that
goes beyond the way people normally understand each other.
But how should we go about distinguishing between belief and
knowledge? I mean, what does really count as
knowledge? Oh. So, um, maybe a
helpful thing to think about in terms of what things
really come to his knowledge is to understand that what
knowledge is, is not just the same thing as
beliefs that happen to be true. Mhm. So
, suppose there's an object and it's aimed at particular
place and then the object is like moving all around
while I'm not looking at it, it's moving all
, it's moving here, it's moving there and then
just randomly it happens to move back to the exact
place that it was when I was, when I
was looking at it, then if I hadn't been
looking at it this whole time, I might believe
it's in this place and it really is in this
place. But I don't know, it's in this
place. It's just, I was just lucky.
So, in a case like that, you might
think, I believe it. And it's true,
but I don't actually know it. So, the
, the key idea now that we were introducing is
that, um, that this ability to figure out
which things people know and which they don't know,
this is something shared with our, with other primates
and this ability to figure out what things people believe
is not. So suppose you do it um this
task now with a chimpanzee. So um I put
something in this, in this place and you're watching
me put it in this place and then you look
away. So just try it out so our viewers
can see. OK. Can you look away for
a second? Yeah. OK. So now while
you're looking at it just stays in this place and
now it's in this place, you can't, you
can't see it. Now turn back. OK.
Now once you turn back, I as the other
, um as a chimpanzee would expect that when you're
trying to get it, say it's a piece of
food that you'd look here and you wouldn't look here
but not consider a different kind of case. So
suppose I put the object in this place and then
you look away. Now, while you're looking late
, let's try, can you demonstrate while you're looking
at the object moves all around, it's moving,
it's moving, it's here, it's here. Ok
. Now, look back. So now just by
chance it happened to end up in the same place
that it was when you looked away. Another question
is where does the chimpanzee expect you to go when
you're trying to find it? And the answer is
chimpanzees are just completely a chance. They think it's
totally random which place you go. So that seems
to indicate chimpanzees can figure out which things you know
, but they can't figure out which things you believe
, you believe it's here, but you don't know
it's here. So they have no idea where you
think it is. Yeah. And from the perspective
of cognitive science, what is more basic representations of
knowledge or representations of belief? And that at least
what we suggest. And this is in a paper
that's where the lead author is, Jonathan Phillips is
that the more basic thing is knowledge. And in
that way, we're sort of going against what a
lot of cognitive scientists have traditionally thought like that.
A lot of cognitive scientists traditionally thought if you want
to understand basically how I make sense of your mind
, the most basic thing to understand is how I
figure out what you think. And then our suggestion
is people can figure out what you think, but
that's not the thing they're using most generally. Maybe
they use that in cases where something weird is happening
. And so they can't use their more basic approach
and the more basic approach is to figure out what
, you know. So I don't know if this
will be a helpful example. But um, I
, if we're going to your home and we're just
walking on the street, I immediately have this sense
that, you know, where your home is and
then my ability to think about the fact that you
know, where your home is. So we're gonna
go to the right place, doesn't rely in any
way on my ability to attribute beliefs to you,
right? So, uh uh and le let's now
talk a little bit about uh causal judgments and norm
violations because you've done some work on that. So
do norm violations interact with causal judgments. And if
so how, yeah, so a lot of studies
show that um when you're judging whether one thing caused
another thing, then people tend to think that people's
judgments about whether this cause that depend on whether they
think that this thing is right or wrong or good
or bad. So you, I'll just give an
example to explain it. So imagine that you're in
the philosophy department and the receptionist has a, has
some pens on her desk. So now, um
the there are like two pens on her desk and
the rule of the department is that administrative assistants are
allowed to take the pens, but professors are not
supposed to take pens from the desk, they're just
supposed to bring their own pens. So I mentioned
one day the administrative assistant and Professor Smith are walking
by the desk and they just each take a pen
. So the administrative assistant takes a pen just like
she's supposed to. And Professor Smith also takes a
pen even though she's totally not supposed to and she's
just completely violating this rule. Now, after they've
both done that, um, there's no pens on
the desk. And so when the receptionist gets a
call, she has a problem, she has no
pen to like, take down the message to know
who caused the problem. In that case, participants
overwhelmingly to say that the recept that the Professor Smith
caused the problem, but the administrative assistant did not
cause the problem. And then in that case,
they're making a causal judgment. They're just judging whether
one thing caused another, but their judgment about whether
something caused something else seems to be shaped in some
way by their judgments of which things are right or
wrong to do. And then over the past few
years, we've been doing all these different kinds of
research to explain why that's happened and why does that
happen? Well, there are a number of different
theories and um it could turn out that our theory
is wrong, but the theory that we adopt is
that it depends is that people's moral judgments are shaping
which possibilities they think of. So in the case
that I just described what happened in the actual world
was that the administrative assistant took a pen and Professor
Smith took a pen. But you could imagine other
possibilities, what we call counter factuals. You could
just imagine other things that could have happened. So
one thing you could imagine is the administrative assistant could
have just not taken a pen, even though there
was no reason for her to do that. And
the professor could have taken a pen. And then
in that case, the problem wouldn't have occurred.
But you would tend not to think about that possibility
because why would the administrative system of not taking that
? And then another possibility you could consider is,
for example, the administrative system takes a pen and
the professor doesn't take a pen. In that case
, also, the problem wouldn't have occurred, but
there's just a much higher probability that you think of
that possibility, the possibility in which people do what
they're supposed to do. And so we developed this
theory according to that, which is science probabilities to
different thoughts. So if you mentioned different things,
you could possibly think, then there's a probability of
thinking certain things and a probability of other thinking other
things and they're different, there are different potential probabilities
and then the degree to which you end up regarding
certain things as causes can be defined in it mathematically
in terms of those probabilities. So in the case
that I just told you given the exact way it
works because there was a higher probability of thinking about
cases in which the professor doesn't take a pen and
in the case in which the administrative assistant doesn't take
a pen, you would more say the professor across
the public. Mhm. Uh, so, uh
, we're going to talk more about the work you've
been doing on, uh, how morality and moral
appraisals affect or at least influence how we think.
Uh, but, uh, I, I mean
, let me ask you another question to introduce a
topic that also we sort of related to that.
So people have this idea or concept of the true
self. So, what is that? What does
that mean? Exactly. Oh, yeah, it's
a, it's a really good question. Try to
understand what it really is. So there's a very
straightforward sense of which it seems like people have it
though. Like, so for example, um,
suppose that, uh, you are faced with this
conflict, which is that you want to have,
you, you're, um, addicted to heroin and
you want to have some heroin, but also at
the very time you want to get clean and then
there's this conflict between you. Now suppose you end
up yielding to the temptation to do more heroin and
then you abandon the desire to get clean. A
lot of people would think that decision that you did
chose, it doesn't reflect what you really want deep
down inside something like you're betraying your true self.
And then by contrast, if you chose the opposite
option, if you said I'm going to, um
, uh, just not do this heroin, I'm
gonna get clean and I get a jug and I
get back with, if you did that, no
one would say you're betraying your true self because deep
down inside what you really wanted to do was to
have no heroin. So in that case, people
have a very clear intuition about which one is the
thing that your true self is calling you to it
. And then there's a much more difficult question,
which is what does that mean? Like what,
what is it that makes us think that one is
the one that's your true self, right? Uh
And I, and I mean, is it that
there are any universals when it comes to how people
think about the true self? Well, we do
find actually that there's something strikingly systematic that you see
across many different people and many different cultures. And
that is that when there's a conflict between two different
things. So part of you is drawn toward one
thing and part of you is drawn to the other
people show a very striking tendency to think that the
one person you really are deep down inside the real
you is the thing that's to the thing that they
think is good. So in the case that I
just described, if you think that during heroin is
bad, you'd be less likely to think that that's
, that your real self. So if different people
have totally opposite views about what is good, then
those different people will have totally opposite views about who
you really are deep down inside. Like if,
if you're caught between A and B and some people
think A is the good thing and some people think
B is the good thing, the people who think
A is the good thing will say deep down inside
the real Ricardo is struggling toward A and the other
people who think B is the good thing will think
deep down in his true self. The real Ricardo
is the thing that's been drawing him to be.
And what about the misanthrope specifically? Do they also
think that the true self is uh is good or
not? Yeah. So some people have this tendency
that they think people are bad. So if you
just ask them on um explicit questions, like,
do you agree with the following statement? You just
can't really trust people, they're gonna do bad stuff
to you, then they say, yeah, people
are terrible. So now the question is they still
think that the true self is good. So in
um some research that was led by Julian Deres,
we, we looked at that question and what we
did was um we told, told participants about a
story about someone who's caught between two things. So
they have a desire to do the morally good thing
and they have a desire to do the morally bad
thing. And then participants were randomly assigned to one
of two questions. So one question is given that
people are copying these two things. Which one do
you predict they'll actually do if someone's copying these two
things, you know, what do you think he's
gonna do? And then it's pretty unsurprising the people
who are very low in misanthropy say he's gonna do
the good thing. And the people who are high
in misanthropy say he's gonna do the bad thing.
But then by contrast, we say, um OK
, there are these two things I'm not asking you
which one he's gonna do. I'm asking you which
one is his true self. Then the people who
are low in misanthropy and the people who are high
in misanthropy both say the true self is the one
drawing him toward what's good. So misanthropes think you're
, they, they still think deep down you're good
. They just think you're not gonna do the thing
that your true self is calling you to do.
But do we know why? That's the case?
I mean, why, even though they still think
that the true self is good, uh they don't
expect that people will behave in a good way.
Why is that? That's really fascinating question. And
it really gets to a deep question of what this
thing even is like, what, what is it
to say that someone has a true self. It
doesn't seem to be something that we're using to predict
what they're actually going to do. It seems to
be something else. I think maybe this won't answer
your question, but maybe just to give a sense
of what this judgment is, it would be helpful
to give an example one of our studies. So
this is a study that was led by George Newman
. And in this study, participants were told about
this guy Mark and there were two different conditions in
one condition. Participants were told Mark as an evangelical
preacher and he travels around the world brings people this
message that homosexuality is a sin and you can be
redeemed from that sin through the power of Jesus.
If you pray, you can like rid yourself of
homosexuality. And then marcus' problem, which is that
he himself is actually gay. And so he himself
is really drawn to other men. And then he
describes this in his speeches and acknowledges it as part
of his own personal struggle. So there's a struggle
within Mark. Um He has desire to be with
other man and he's a belief that it's morally wrong
. So which part is his true self? In
that case, I just described liberal participants to tend
to say Marx, true yourself is the part that
um is being drawn to other men. And the
conservatives tend to say Mars yourself is the part that
believes that it's morally wrong. I know if you
can kind of feel that intuitively. But now suppose
we switch it. So now we're gonna say America
is this person who travels all around the world,
bringing to people this message that people of all sexual
orientations should be treated equally. And then he teaches
people techniques that they can use to treat gay people
with respect. But Mark himself has a problem and
the problem is that he himself finds himself feeling disgusted
by gay people. And then he acknowledges this fully
and just recognized it as a part of his own
personal struggle. So now again, his emotions and
his moral beliefs are are out of um fighting against
each other, but now in the opposite direction.
So this time, which do people think it's,
is his true self? Here, it's reversed.
The liberals tend to say is more a belief that
you should treat people with all sexual orientations equally.
That's his true self. If you could just get
rid of this disgust, then he'd be able to
more fully express the person, he was all alone
. And then the conservatives tend to say that emotion
of disgust, that is his true self. And
if you could get rid of the moral belief,
then you'd be able to express the person he really
is all about. So now we face this question
, which is the question that you just posed,
you know, how do we make sense of what
this thing is? It doesn't seem to be something
that people are using to predict what Mark is going
to do. It seems to be playing some other
role in their way of thinking about who Mark really
is. But then, uh, people's own moral
values influence how they think about the true self.
And what they say is the true self of someone
they are evaluating. Yeah, exactly. And people's
moral beliefs affect that and then it doesn't seem to
be that they only affects judgments about the true self
, let's say of a human being, they seem
to also affect judgments about the essence of other things
other than human beings. So say, there's some
band you like and now suppose the band has different
albums over time. See, their first album was
really amazing. And then by the third album they've
, like, totally sold out and then the,
the band is just like, doing some, like
, corporate schlock to sell more records. Yeah.
I thought you could ask the question, like all
those different albums, which one reflects, like what
this band is really all about. Like the true
essence of this band. Then you get the same
effect that people say, whichever is the best one
that's what affects like the real essence of the band
. No one ever thinks, um, the schlocky
corporate stuff. That's what the band was really all
about. And then they were betraying their true essence
in their first album when they created this amazing music
, we're supposed to think about the essence of the
United States. So the United States has done various
different things. For example, there's maybe a lot
of freedom, but there's also a lot of racism
. And then you might ask the question, you
know, what's the real essence of the United States
? What's the United States really all about? And
then different people have different views about which things about
the United States are the good ones and which are
the bad ones. But people seem to think whichever
is the good thing about the United States. That's
what the United States is really all about. So
this thing that we see for judgments about the true
self, it seems like it arises for judgments about
the self, arises for like what you are really
all about, but not just because you're because of
you, because you're a human being, it also
arises for nations, for bands, for all sorts
of different things. Like if I write a philosophy
paper and it has different sections and some are good
and some are bad, whichever section you think is
the good one, you'll think that's the real heart
of what my paper is really all about. And
, uh, I mean, I asked you if
uh moral beliefs influence the way people think about the
true self of a particular somebody. So, but
uh, does it work also the other way around
? I mean, do beliefs about the true self
influence moral judgment. That's a great question. We
, we have some evidence in recent work with Michael
printing that seems to suggest that, that they do
. So, the basic idea would be, um
, suppose, for example, that, um someone
is, um, he's caught between two different kind
of romantic interests like a woman is trying to choose
between two different men. And then suppose you learn
, she's drawn to one and she's also drawn to
the other, but deep down in her truest heart
, she's more drawn to this one and less to
that one that makes people think that this one is
actually the good person that people think the thing that
your true self is drawing you toward. Probably that
thing is good. And it feels like a,
like a really fundamental kind of heuristic that people use
sometimes in their own decision making that, that when
they're trying to figure out what's right, they seem
to be drawn to the thought that whatever their truest
deepest self is pulling them toward, that must really
be the right thing. Mhm. And I mean
, do judgments moral judgments regarding uh the goodness or
the badness of someone's behavior, have any influence in
how we think about them being happy or not,
or if they deserve praise or blame, that is
uh thinking about a particular agent's behavior in moral terms
, also influence how we think about it in terms
of some other psychological dimensions like happiness, praise blame
. And so on, we, we get these
very strong effects for happiness. So an obvious thought
you might have about what it is to be happy
. Is it being happy? It just means feeling
really good all the time, not feeling bad.
And I don't know, thinking your life is going
well, this is about his mental states that you
have. But for some reason, we're finding that
people's moral judgments affect whether you see someone's happy or
not. So imagine two different cases. So imagine
this person who feels really good all the time,
doesn't feel bad and thinks her life is going great
. And the reason is she's like a high school
student who is um really uh has close friends in
her high school and is like working to help the
disadvantaged, like on her spare time and it's a
good relationship with her parents and so forth. Then
people think she's truly happy but not consider a different
person I met with someone who's more like Regina George
, the character from mean girls. So she feels
really good and she doesn't feel bad and she thinks
her life is going great. And the reason is
because she's the most popular kid in the class.
And whenever anyone else tries to challenge her or something
, she just like insults them and demeans them and
just dominates everyone. She has no real friends,
no real interests doesn't really care about anything. And
it's just trying to like, get to the top
of this popularity contest, then people feel when you
give that case a little, I much more torn
about whether the person is happy. So a lot
of people seem to have this feeling like, well
, there's clearly a sense in which she's happy.
You just said she feels good. But on the
other hand, they feel like no, but there's
some deeper sense of when she doesn't feel happy at
all in some sense, what she has is not
true happiness where true happiness seems to be something that
you can laugh even if you're feeling pretty great.
Uh But uh I mean, when it comes to
happiness, this is, I guess a complicated concept
, isn't it the case that conceptions of happiness vary
cross culturally. We don't find that in the studies
that we've done. So you work with Yang,
we um why we and she translated all of this
into Chinese and then just ran all these cases in
um in China with Chinese people. And then we
find exactly the same thing arising that people say the
person who's morally bad isn't really happy. And then
, and then tried it with Children. So um
if you imagine like just asking the same kind of
question to a four year old, and then we
find again the same thing, Children also show the
same effect. So overall, it seems like what
, what's going on is that this effect seems to
be not something that's just arising I don't know because
of certain weird idiosyncrasies of what's going on in western
culture, in the 20 twenties. It's something that
is in very young Children before they've had the chance
to kind of learn all the subtleties of exactly how
words are used. And it's something that arises across
very different cultures. It's a very good question why
it's happening, but it doesn't seem to be happening
because it's something more like about, um kind of
just uh certain books we happen to have read or
certain ways we happen to use this one word.
Uh And I, I would like to ask you
now about uh folk morality. Do, do people
, for example, tend to believe in objective moral
truths? Yeah, that's a great question. So
in, in philosophy, there's been a really long
and profound question uh inquiry into the question are their
moral truths objective? Could there really be a fact
of the matter about some moral question? And within
philosophy, there's some people who think the answer is
yes and some people who think the answer is no
. But typically people on both sides of that dispute
say that ordinary folks think the answer is definitely yes
. So the people who say that the answer is
yes, they were defending the ordinary view and the
people who say the answer is no, say the
ordinary view is wrong. There aren't objective well truths
in the way people think they ordinarily are. But
why do people say that just try asking a few
people around you. And you'll find immediately that people
don't always say that their objective moral is pe different
people you ask will give you different answers and different
questions, the ways of asking the question will give
you different answers. It seems like what's happening and
you could see this. I think immediately if you
just asked a few friends is that people regard this
as a confusing question that they think it's a difficult
question to answer and they're kind of drawn in competing
directions. So we ran a whole series of studies
and that's what they seem to show that um people
are confused about this. It's like difficult and de
depending on various things that you do, you can
kind of push people in very different directions. But
uh I, I mean, o of course,
I don't know if you controlled for these in those
studies but uh the way people think about morality and
moral proofs as being objective or not, this,
is it influence or do you know if it's influenced
in any way by uh political beliefs? For example
, I mean, beca because the there's this,
sometimes we hear this idea that uh conservative people when
compared to liberal people would believe more in objective moral
truths. But I, I don't know if that
has any scientific or experimental philosophical support to it or
not. Yeah, that is true. So in
studies by this is not my own work. But
in studies by Louis SS, he finds this correlation
that more conservative people more believe in objective moral truths
and more liberal people less believe in objective moral truths
. So that's just a correlation. It doesn't mean
that the political beliefs are affecting the, um,
the beliefs about the nature of normality. It could
be a different way where there's some deeper fact about
a person and that affects your political beliefs and it
also just affects your beliefs about morality. But in
any case, you're totally right, though different people
with different political beliefs tend to have different beliefs about
whether they're objective morals. Uh, and so,
but when it comes to moral relativism, do we
have any idea about how prevalent it is among people
and, uh, across different cultures? I mean
, is it that it's very common or not?
Yes. So in studies to address this question,
we try, um, uh, to test whether
people are moral relatives by giving them the, the
following kind of cases. So they're gonna be three
different conditions. And so imagine there's some person in
, I don't know, New Jersey and this person
does something like, for example, he murders his
own child. And now suppose that you say that
what he did was morally wrong. And then I
say what he did is totally fine. And then
participants are asked the question given that Ricardo and Josh
said, opposite things about this does one of them
have to be wrong, Ricardo or Josh or could
it be that neither of them is wrong? And
then in that case, participants overwhelmingly say one of
us has to be wrong. Ok. Now consider
a different case, suppose there's discrepancies in New Jersey
, then he murders his own child. And then
I say that, um, what that, what
he did is morally wrong. And then there's someone
else in a completely different culture, say this is
the hunter gatherer living in the Amazon. And then
that person says what this person did isn't wrong at
all. It's totally fine. Then given that I
said this thing and this other person from his other
cultures said the opposite. Does one of us have
to be wrong? Or could we both be right
on that case, people are right about at the
midpoint of the scale. So in that case,
participants don't say definitely one of you has to be
wrong or definitely could be that you're neither of you
is wrong. They're kind of like neither here nor
there. Now consider a third condition. That's like
an even more distinct culture. So ma that there
are these extraterrestrial beings, they're called the PS and
the P tars don't have any of the interest that
we have. They're not, they don't care about
like love and friendship and like um helping others.
None of that, all they care about is maximizing
the total number of Pentagons in the universe. And
then, for example, if one of them becomes
too old and tired and sick to accomplish this task
, they just kill that and just turn him into
a Pentagon and then none of them see anything wrong
with that. No, I mentioned that this person
in New Jersey kills his own child and I say
that's really morally bad. And one of the panthers
says, no, it's totally fine. There's nothing
bad about it at all. Then in that case
, does one of us have to be wrong me
or the Panther or could it be that neither of
us is wrong in that kind of case, participants
tend to say neither of you has to be wrong
. So it's a little bit unclear what to make
of this and different um philosophers have had very different
thoughts about it, but it seems to at least
suggest there, there's something that draws us toward thinking
in a relativist way as we start thinking about um
judges who are more and more different from each other
. Mhm. Uh So it seems that also that
uh people consistently make sense of moral events in terms
of agents and patients do, do we know why
? That's the case? So right there, there's
really important work, not, not by me,
that's indicating it a really fundamental aspect of how people
think about moral situations is that there is kind of
true rules, there's the role of the agent and
the role of the patient So I don't know if
um if the Russian army killed some innocent people in
a Ukrainian town, then the Russian army would be
the agent and the innocent people who got killed will
be the patient. And then uh research on this
topic has explored these two rules, these fundamental rules
and morality and uh how things like that work.
Like, for example, some research seems to suggest
that it's very hard to see someone as occupying bulls
ws like in two different events. They, they
would be hard in the case. I just described
to think that for example, the um people would
tend not to think that those people were the victims
of the Russian army, but also they themselves are
perpetrators who harm other people within their towns, right
? So then the question arises, why does morality
work like that? Why do we have these two
fundamental rules? And one possible answer you could give
is that it's just because it's something about morality,
morality is like that. But at least what we
suggested was may, maybe it's not, maybe the
reason that things work that way is because it's something
much more general about human cognition, how the human
mind works. There people tend to think about agents
and patients or sometimes they're called agents and themes in
general. And some evidence from that comes from like
the structure of human language that if you think about
um which thing goes in the subject position of a
sentence and which thing goes in the object position of
the sentence? It it's, it's not random.
It always seems to be the agent and the patient
. So just to give you a sense of what
I mean, you know how we have the word
, for example. Um Great. So you couldn't
say like I broke his bone and that would mean
like that I was the one who caused the bone
to break or like John broke Fred's bone or we
could have like um hurt like John hurt Fred.
But no, I imagine we tried to create a
verb that's like the reverse of hurt. It's called
a Schmidt. And then John Schmidt uh Fred Schmit
did um John just means the same thing as John
hurt. Fred that no language has a word that
works like that and you can kind of feel it
immediately like that we could never have that, that
verb could never exist. So it feels like there's
this very basic connection we have uh idea we have
about agency and patient is such that we're always gonna
put the agent and subject position and the patient or
in this is sometimes called the theme in the object
position. Mhm uh And since we're talking here about
uh folk philosophy, what tend to be people's ideas
about free will, I mean, is the belief
in free will, a human universal. Well,
it, it, it's really interesting that what you
find if you ask people in the United States about
free, well, like say we just looked around
here is that people find it confusing. So um
if you ask like folks right around here, if
I ask them certain kinds of questions, what I
get is that people would immediately recognize that that's like
a really confusing question and then they're like torn in
different directions. Some people would say one thing,
some people say another thing, a lot of people
would just openly admit that that's like a really hard
problem. So that like you said about universality,
a really question now is um is is why why
do people find it confusing around here? And when
I was um first starting to work on this issue
, uh what I thought the answer was is that
it's due in part certain very specific kind of talks
about Western culture that make us find it confusing.
But also, I mean, people in Western culture
and then, and then I was totally wrong.
So I um started researching this topic with um my
colleague Sean Nichols who had the opposite guess about what
was right? And I just got completely owned it
is in no way. Did that turn out to
be true? What happened instead was that this kind
of intuition that we, these kind of intuitions that
we have in in Western culture that are pulling us
in opposite directions and confusing us and making the question
seem like a really puzzling one those arise really universally
. So in in a beautiful recent study where the
first author was Ivar Henkin, um participants were recruited
from all different places across the world and given questions
about free will. And if you look at the
Western culture, what you find is that people are
very divided. Some people say one thing, some
people say the other, it's obviously a really confusing
question. And then that exact same confusion arose in
every world region that they looked at every different continent
showed the same confusion with the same kind of percentage
of people saying one thing and saying the other thing
. So it's really like this feeling we have that
but it's confusing that it's puzzling that there's something going
wrong when we think about free will. It's not
because of something about our weird culture. It's because
of something about human way of understanding action. But
I I mean when you mentioned there that uh when
you ask people certain questions, you get the sense
that they are a bit confused about free will.
Could you give us examples of some of those questions
just for us to get a better sense of what
we're talking about here? Absolutely. So in one
of the early studies we did about this, we
were interested in the question, what do people think
when I think about this kind of question abstractly just
like theoretically? And what did you think about this
question? And the thing about individual cases with individual
behaviors. OK. So to address this question,
we told people about this imaginary universe, we called
it universe a and we said like, OK,
imagine in this, this imaginary universe is totally deterministic
. So what that means is everything that happens was
completely caused by the thing that happened before, which
was completely caused by the thing that happened before that
it's clearly caused by the thing that happened before that
all the way back to the very beginning of the
universe. So if you consider how things were,
you know, one second after the universe first began
, that completely caused the thing that would happen next
and next and next. So that given the way
things were at the very beginning of the universe and
given the laws of physics in this universe, you
and I would have to be having this conversation right
now. It could be like in principle predicted from
the 1st, 2nd after the universe we have.
So OK, do you understand this idea of the
universe? All right, people get this. I
got. Yeah. And then we said no,
um here's a question and then were split into two
conditions in one condition. They got an abstract question
. The abstract question was, can anyone in this
universe ever be morally responsible for anything they ever do
? And an overwhelmingly participant saying no in this universe
that you described universe, a no one can ever
be more responsible for anything. It's just not possible
. Determinist the universe. That's what philosophers call incompatible
with. It's called incompatible because it's saying moral responsibility
is incompatible with determinism. Then in the other people
got a very different question. It was a concrete
question. So participants, which will imagine one guy
in that universe, a guy in universe a he
falls in love with his secretary and he wants to
like leave his wife and family for a secretary.
So he sets up an inn device in his basement
that burns down the house and kills his own wife
and Children. Is that guy more than responsible that
guy in universe A is he morally responsible for what
he did? And their participants overwhelmingly say yes.
So these are obviously like logically inconsistent participants are saying
in universe A in the abstract, no one can
ever be more responsible for anything they do. But
they're also saying that one guy who was in universe
A is totally more responsible for this one thing that
he did. So, a and since we've been
talking about moral judgments and how they affect or influence
, uh thinking about different topics, uh The uh
what uh is it the case that what you just
mentioned there points to uh moral judgment also influencing how
we think about free will. I mean, in
that particular case, uh is, should we conclude
that if people want to blame someone, they tend
to attribute free will to their actions? Yeah.
At first I thought that was right. The thing
that you just said and then in, in a
really beautiful series of studies, Florent Cage showed that
it, it's not right. So there really is
a difference between concrete things and abstract things. So
when it's concrete, people think it's due to um
to your um uh when it's concrete, they think
that you, you're, you're responsible for it and
you do it freely and when it's abstract, I
think you don't, but it's not due to,
for example, you being really upset about the thing
the person did and really wanting to blame them.
So for example, if you start dialing down how
bad it is to something that's just kind of like
feels bad in the kind of a technical sense,
but isn't really like something that people would be outraged
by like in my example, people still think the
person is more the responsible and then coal looked at
people who have frontal temporal dementia. And so as
a result of this um disorder, they don't feel
angry at people in the same way they normally would
in cases like this and those people have been shown
to have very different judgments about certain kinds of matters
. But unless they show the exact same pattern of
judgments. So if things like it's really something about
the concreteness, it's about thinking about an individual,
human being doing an individual thing and it's not something
about um the rage that you feel against this person
who killed his own Children but OK, whatever it
is behind it, uh we see these occurring cross
culturally. I mean, do people tend to,
when they are presented with abstract or concrete scenarios,
do they tend to think about them in similar ways
? Cross culturally. We, we do. Yeah
, it looks like we do. So we do
find in one study that participants in the abstract think
about these things in, in a similar way cross
culturally. And then we also find in the um
this isn't, so that was in the um uh
Sarkissian Nicholson, I did. And then in the
study that I just mentioned from Heine Kanen, participants
are given like a little concrete vignette that's designed in
such a way that, that it's confusing, you
know, different people say different things in the United
States. People are very divided, you know,
half the people say one thing and half the people
say another thing. And then if you look at
China, people are also very divided. If you
look at different countries in Africa, people are also
very divided there. It feels like that division is
itself something that's called that we're seeing across many different
cultures. I find they're quite striking like that.
If you think about what you might expect to be
the same across cultures, you might think there are
these things that are really fundamental to just being able
to survive in our world. Like things like,
for example, judgments about how it's appropriate to treat
your own Children or something like that, that you
could imagine in no culture would people think it's OK
to do certain terrible things to their Children? And
that would be a universal thought. What we're seeing
here is these very obscure seeming like metaphysical questions about
free will. Judgments on these questions seem to be
universal. And that, that seems like a really
puzzling phenomenon that it's the kind of thing you might
have thought would vary considerably and that there would be
no reason to expect that you kind of be built
to the nature of our cognition to give similar judgments
on questions like those. So uh and I mean
, when it comes to finding these universals, these
human universals, when it comes to philosophical intuitions and
we're going to get into some more of them,
we talked about free will here. Uh Do you
also, are you also interested in trying to understand
where do those universals come from? If for example
, they are the result of evolution by natural selection
operating on a cognitive level or some other thing?
Yeah. A absolutely. So we, we would
absolutely want to know why these things seem to arise
across cultures. So maybe it's too much to say
these things are universal. It's not that we would
really have evidence for that, you know, from
any study. But I think that they're surprisingly stable
and you know, a really difficult question arises as
to why they would be so stable. So maybe
it would be helpful to give an example of the
kind of thing that just feels like super weird and
kind of like just a very strange quirk, but
turns out to be surprisingly stable across cultures. So
this is an effect that was first discovered by um
Wesley Buck Walter and James Beanie. And then these
cross cultural studies were done by um mj Kim and
Yuan, y So what we Lee Buchalter and James
BB were just interested in when people think, you
know, something versus just really something, it turns
out to be true, like in the case that
I just described before, you know, so they
had the idea that maybe mortality affects it. So
here's the kind of study that they ran in one
condition, someone's the mayor of a town and um
he gets some uh has a meeting with someone who's
like, you know, one of his employees and
the employee says, ok, we've got this new
policy that we're considering and this new policy is going
to really increase campaign contributions to you. So you're
gonna make tons of money and it's also going to
bring jobs to people from the town. And then
he says, I don't really care about bringing jobs
to people in this town. All I want to
do is just get as much money as possible for
myself. So he says, to um sign this
contract that's going to adopt the policy. So he
goes in to sign the contract and then as he's
just about to sign it, the corporation switches it
for a completely different contract. So the contract he
signed is not at all the one that he thought
he was gonna sign. But then it turned out
that that other contract, the one he really did
sign, ends up bringing jobs to people in this
town. So he believed he would bring jobs to
people in town and he did bring jobs to the
people in town. Did he know that he was
gonna bring jobs to the people in town. In
that case, most people say no, ok.
Now consider another case. The assistant comes to the
mayor and says, we've got this new policy.
It's gonna make huge amounts of money for you.
So you'll get all these campaign contributions, but it's
also gonna cut jobs for people in the town.
So people in the town are gonna really be hurt
by this policy. And the they says, I
don't care about the people in the town. I
know they're gonna cut, you know, it's gonna
cut their jobs, but I don't care about that
. Let's just go ahead and, and do this
. So he goes to sign the contract and then
the corporation, he's gonna sign the contract to it
switches out for a different contract. So the one
he's signing has all different provisions says all different stuff
. But that other country does end up cutting jobs
to the town. Did he know that he was
going to cut jobs to people in the town?
In that case, people say yes, that just
feels like a really weird, like quirky thing about
our way of understanding knowledge. And then um Kim
and um Yuan studied that same thing by translating all
of these vignettes. I just gave you into Korean
and Chinese and then running them on Korean and Chinese
people. And the same thing happens among participants in
South Korea and China. So why would that be
? It? It feels like this weird thing I
just told you, it doesn't feel like we would
have evolved to have that exact quality, this quality
of making knowledge judgments based on morality. It,
I don't know if it, if it's somehow in
some way built into us innately, it must be
that somehow just the side effect or byproduct's of other
cognitive capacities we have that serve some other use.
It's very hard to see what might be going on
here. I feel like it's very puzzling why these
things we're seeing are happening across different cultures. OK
. So they could still be the result or a
by-product of certain uh cognitive adaptations, but they are
not necessarily adaptations themselves or are not necessarily evolved themselves
. It feels very unlikely in the case that I
just told you that human beings there was selective pressure
for making knowledge judgments in a way that's infused by
morality. I mean, that one thing doesn't seem
like it was really being selected for. It could
be that our judgments about that one thing are the
product of these cognitive processes and those processes were selected
for in some way. But those processes also do
other things that seems like it could make sense.
It could be that there's convergent cultural evolution. It's
a very complex problem to understand why these things are
so stable across cultures. Mhm But uh I asked
you as an example about uh free will but have
you or some of your other colleagues in experimental philosophy
uh studied uh people's philosophical intuitions in general? I
mean, and if so do they tend to vary
a lot or are they stable across, for example
, demographic groups and situations? Well, that's a
wonderful question. So first of all, obviously,
the answer is that in some ways they're stable and
in some ways they're different. I mean, we
could have known that before we ran any studies there
. It's not that there's no differences ever between cultures
on anything and there's no differences I don't know between
genders on anything. And it's also not that every
single thing is totally different between cultures and between genders
and then different people have different opinions about how to
understand what, what we actually discovered. I mean
, given that we found that some things differ and
some things stay the same. You know, what
should we be struck by my own opinion? And
this is certainly a matter of debate. Is that
what we should really be struck by is just how
similar everything is that it's not that everything stayed the
same, it's not that everything was different, but
overall things were just amazingly amazingly similar. So just
to give an example, there was a really nice
paper by Edelberg Thompson and Nus that looked at a
whole bunch of different things that people thought might differ
across genders. So these were all um uh effects
that someone had actually said in existing literature. I
said this is going to differ between men and women
. And then for all of them, I think
it was maybe 21 different things or 18 different things
. Some of them like that, that they checked
whether there was a difference and it's not that they
found no differences, it's that they found one difference
. So approximately what they found is one intuitions on
one thing did differ between men and women and on
the other, you know, around 19, all
of those were the same. So that doesn't mean
there are no differences, there are differences. But
overall, the message seems to be, these things
are really, really similar. And then I feel
like what, what we're seeing especially is um if
you consider certain kinds of um moral judgments, for
example, or judgments about religious things are, are
explicitly transmitted to people. Like people, like your
parents tell you about morality. Yeah. Then obviously
we get cross cultural differences on those things. So
. Mhm. So, if you grew up in
Iowa or you grew up in Brazil, you're gonna
have different judgments about morality and it's really obvious why
it's like, people are just explicitly telling you about
morality. But most things that philosophers study are things
that no one ever tells you about. Like when
you're growing up, no one ever says, you
know, I just really want you to understand that
whether someone has knowledge depends in part on whether something
is morally good or morally bad. Like then you
just kind of pick stuff up but no one ever
talks about it and on those things, the things
that no one ever talks about, we really seem
to be getting amazing degrees of sonari. Yeah,
that, that's very interesting. And I, and
I mean, another interesting question, I guess about
all of these that we've been talk about we've been
talking about is so this is about folk philosophy.
But I mean, philosophers themselves are also people.
So I mean, when it comes to uh the
variation, specifically, the variation we find across different
groups of people, do you think that by having
an understanding of what's behind that variation, we could
also have a better understanding of why professional philosophers differ
in their views of different philosophical topics? You mean
why different philosophers have different views, maybe we can
understand it. Yeah, that's a great question.
So, um the, the first answer is,
I, I don't know, I don't know the
answer to the question. And then, um there
, there has been some research that tries to get
out why different philosophers have different views and whether it
has to do with differences between the, the different
philosophers and then I'll just talk a little bit about
what has been found. So, in a really
nice study by Yaden, the result was that one
result was that demographic factors don't predict it. So
different philosophers think different stuff. I don't know about
free will, about whether morality is objective and so
forth. And then different philosophers are, you know
, themselves from, from different cultures. And so
some are men, some are women, some are
non-binary like that doesn't predict their judgments. Then a
separate question was for example, whether facts but their
personalities affect their, their judgments about these things.
And overall, I would say um in the study
of philosophers, they mostly didn't. So, so
facts about like what kind of person you are have
overall, I would say very little impact on,
on what your philosophical views were but not exclusively.
So for example, if you ask professional philosophers,
whether they do drugs, so do you use recreational
drugs? And then you ask them, are there
objective truths about art like which art is better and
which art is worse? Those two things are correlated
. So the more drugs you use, the less
you think there is like objective truths about art and
that seems to be totally real. So there is
no, in just in that case, for example
, certain kinds of correlations between your personality or the
kind of life you're living in your philosophical. And
then in a series of studies that feel really funny
to me, Nick Bird was looking at um the
relationship between uh like being reflective in the sense that
for example, you can solve certain logical problems correctly
and um and having certain answers to philosophical questions,
but then this might not seem very surprising. But
um if you ask ordinary folks say, you,
you just go into like a classroom and you give
everyone like a bunch of logic puzzles and you can
see who's better, who gets the best right answer
and who gets the wrong answer. Then what you
find is that um that predicts uh judgments about certain
philosophical questions. So just as an example, um
in the case that I gave you earlier where I
was seeing like um imagine that this person who kills
his wife and family, the, the more you
um get logic, right, the more you think
he's not more responsible for what he did. OK
. So this is the weird thing that Bird discovered
if you know, run it on philosophers. So
you're running it on or philosophy professors. It still
happens that the philosophy professors who get the logic problems
, right? Tend to have different answers than the
philosophy professors who don't. So that feels like a
very strange fact. But he did find it.
I, I think that the, the, the
broader answer to your question is that I, I
think as a philosopher, when I consider these questions
, like the age old questions of philosophy that people
have been discussing for thousands of years, I feel
torn, like I feel drawn in one direction and
drawn in another. And then eventually I might make
up my mind like maybe I'm torn. But I
decided on this. I think one question you could
ask is do these theories explain why I eventually decided
on this? And someone else decides on that another
question you ask, you could ask is do these
theories explain why both of us are torn in the
first place? I think it's definitely the second,
but at the very least we're really getting some explanation
of, of why people feel confused, if not
an explanation of why different people resolve the confusion in
different ways. Mhm But I mean, do you
think we should at least expect that individual differences in
cognition wherever they stem from, would have an impact
on uh philosopher's views or not? Yeah. Well
, this in the street that I was just talking
about, it's sort of a mixed band in that
. What the study did is it looks at a
very large number of different philosophical views and a very
large number of um individual differences in human cognition and
overwhelmingly, the individual difference, variables don't predict their
philosophical views. So if you could consider all the
possible pairs, just overwhelmingly, there's no prediction.
And then if you look at most of the philosophical
views, what you find is that none of the
individual, different variables predict them. But, but
even though that's true, um we do find that
some philosophical views are predicted by some individual differences.
And the one example that I just gave was um
beliefs about what their objective truths about what's artistically good
really are predicted by something. I, I think
we might find other similar things like it, it
might be that there are some things going on.
It doesn't feel like that's gonna be like this overwhelming
thing that there's like a kind of personality that draws
you toward something or something else. Maybe there's personalities
that draw you towards certain methods. I don't know
what it will turn out to be true. Ok
. So, uh now to also try to get
into the production of scientific knowledge and since we've been
talking about moral judgment a lot, uh do we
know if uh people's moral judgments also influence the intuitions
they hold uh in folk psychology and moral cognition,
for example. Oh, yeah. Well, a
really surprising result that we get again and again is
that um moral intuitions affect what's called folk psychology.
So, folk psychology is the ability to just figure
out what's going on in other people's minds, like
what people are. So, the example I gave
before was about the true self that, um,
when you're, whether you, what you think is
morally good or morally bad affects what you think is
going on deep down in the other percent. But
maybe the most well known, um, uh,
result I have along those lines is not, not
about the true self. It's about just whether someone
did something intentionally like did they do it on purpose
? So I'll just give you two different cases and
they're just gonna do for morally. So here's the
first case. So imagine the vice president of a
company goes to the CEO. It's OK. We've
got this new policy. It's gonna make huge amounts
of money for our company, but it's also gonna
harm the environment. And the CEO says, look
, I know it's gonna harm the environment. I
don't care at all about that. All I care
about is just making as much money as we possibly
can. So let's implement the policy. So they
implement the policy and then sure enough, it harms
the environment and the participants are asked, did the
CEO do it on purpose? Did this CEO do
it intentionally? And there are people overwhelmingly say yes
, the CEO did it intentionally if you ask them
why most participants say something like, well, he
totally knew that he was gonna harm the environment and
then he did it anyway. But we thought maybe
there's something more going on. It's not just about
the knowledge. So suppose you just changed the word
harm to help. So we're gonna leave everything else
the same. Ok. The vice president goes to
the CEO and says we've got this new policy,
it's gonna make huge amounts of money for our company
and it's also gonna help the environment. And the
CEO says, look, you know, it's gonna
help the environment, but I don't care at all
about that. All I care about is just making
as much money as we possibly can. So let's
implement the policy so they implement the policy and then
sure enough, it helps the environment. Did he
help the environment? Intentionally? Other participants overwhelmingly saying
no. So thinking about those two cases, it
feels like this really weird thing is going on that
the only difference between them is that one is about
doing something bad and one is about doing something good
. The question people are being asked isn't about like
whether they deserve blame or praise or anything like that
. It's just being asked, did they do it
on purpose and judgments of whether it's bad or good
or somehow affecting judgments about whether you did it on
purpose. And so I if moral judgments influence the
intuitions people hold when it comes to psychology, can
that also translate into the production of scientific knowledge?
I mean, can moral judgments also affect the scientists
themselves. Oh, yeah. So you mean when
scientists are trying to answer these questions, maybe they
themselves are kind of being driven. Yeah, that's
a really wonderful question. And, um, what
, what we really want to know to answer your
question is like something like when you, if you
look at the actual evolution of research programs are those
research programs being driven by, by these moral judgments
? And it's very hard for us to do that
to study that question. And the reason is it
is hard to run an experiment. Like you'd want
to be like, OK, we randomly sign different
scientific research programs to different moral statuses. But we
can't do anything like that scientific research programs just happen
. However they happen, then we can just study
them. Mhm The thing that we did and I'm
not sure if this is this might really not help
to in a deeper way, answer your question.
You should just run experiments where we ask scientists questions
. So we, we um we just had scientists
and then we're asking them like, consider this case
, can you apply this concept to this case?
And then we do get effects of morality. So
I'll just give you one of these things. So
we ask people about the concept of being innate.
And then, um and then, uh we said
, um we give them different questions and then we
asked these scientists like biologists, linguists, psychologists in
these different cases is this thing in it. And
then what we do see is the effect of morality
. So, um, well, here's an example
, participants were told, imagine there's this trait,
it's called trait X. And now imagine people's genes
are such that if any, if their parents ever
treat them with kindness, then um they're gonna develop
trade X. But everyone's parents treat them with kindness
at least sometimes. So everyone develops trade X is
trade X in it and their participants tend to say
yes. And now, I mean, the person
was in the other condition were given the sy case
, they were told, imagine there's trait, it's
called trade X. And people's genes are such that
if their parents are ever mean to them, they'll
develop trade act, but everyone's parents are mean to
them at least sometimes. So everyone develops trade X
is trade act in the and their participants seem to
say no about participants. I don't mean like um
just, you know, random people on the street
. I mean, these are psychologists, linguists,
biologists, people who are using this concept. So
at least in their answers to these questions, these
scientists judgments are being affected by immorality. So I
, I mean, at uh can we at least
say that um scientists are not immune to their own
moral judgments when they are producing knowledge? Right.
Yeah. Well, we can definitely say that there's
not something within the minds of the individual scientists that
makes this not have an effect. And then the
key question that we would face if we really wanted
to answer your question. And I'm not sure if
our data speak to your larger question is not a
question about what's going on in the mind of each
individual scientist, but a question about the larger kind
of social structures that allow scientific research to progress.
So it's not like um when you're trained as a
scientist, you develop some special thing in your brain
that allows you to not have morality influence it,
that is not happening. So if there was some
way that morality would not influence things or not influence
it in quite the same way or, or have
a decreased influence or anything like that, it,
it wouldn't be something in the mind of the individual
scientists. It would have to be something in the
whole way that science is structured. Like for example
, the fact that that um you're not just seeing
stuff, you're trying to get it um published in
a journal and the peer reviewers on that journal might
have different moral judgments than you. And so you're
the way that you're gonna paper is gonna eventually turn
out is not going to be just a pure reflection
of your own moral judgments, but also of this
larger um interpersonal structure that involves people with very different
moral judgments, all kind of working together to eventually
create a series of publications that actually get published in
journals. Mhm. No, I also asked you
about that because people today are discussing a lot,
the potential effects that, uh, moral values and
political values more specifically of, of course, the
relationship between morality and politics is not, uh,
completely well under, I mean, I've talked with
political scientists and political psychologists on the show and it's
complicated to really understand what's the real relationship between morality
and politics or moral values and political values. But
anyway, people uh now uh nowadays are discussing a
lot uh the potential negative impacts of uh certain political
ideologies within academia and so on. And I mean
, I was trying to understand if some of your
work when it comes in this case, not necessarily
having to do with politics, but more with moral
judgment if it would tell us something or have something
to perhaps add to depth discussion and to what extent
we should or shouldn't be worried about uh people's beliefs
basically. Yeah, our, our work con the
work some of the work that we've done recently contributes
to that question in a very small way. So
if you will be disappointed with a very small contribution
, we may maybe it will be helpful, maybe
be interesting. So um one question that people have
often um been troubled by is the question about the
influence of essentialism on prejudice. So the thought is
um uh people have certain kind of scientific beliefs um
by, by scientifically I don't mean, um,
beliefs of people who are scientists. I meant,
like, if you're just an ordinary person you have
scientific beliefs because I don't know, you go to
high school, you just start to develop, like
, beliefs about scientific questions. Mhm. One kind
of belief that you could have is what people sometimes
call an essentialist belief. So you could think.
Um, I don't know. For example, I
, I'm Jewish and some people think, um,
there's some sort of like, um, Jewish essence
that's sort of like biological, that all Jewish people
have and differentiates them from not Jewish people. And
then it's been a real concern in our field that
, um, those beliefs, essentialist beliefs might give
rise to prejudice. The, the more you centralize
a certain group, like, for example, the
more you think there's like a Jewish essence, the
more you'll be prejudiced against that group, for example
, the more you'll be anti-semitic. So, thought
that was right. Then you might think instead of
just seeing whatever we think is true about these kind
of questions regarding genetic basis of racial groups or something
like that. We have a real reason, a
, a moral reason to not say certain things because
seeing those things might increase prejudice, increase discrimination,
which I find it to be a very plausible view
. So, um, April Ba and I,
we thought that view was right. And so we
, um, we wanted to, uh, sort
of build on it and extend it in certain ways
. And so we ran a whole series of studies
in which we have manipulated the degree to which people
thought there was kind of a genetic essence of a
particular social group. And then we checked to see
whether there was a downstream effect on, on prejudice
or stereotyping. And in all of the studies,
again and again, we found the same result.
So here's what the result is. First of all
, there is a correlation between those two things.
So the more people centralize, the more they think
, the more they are prejudiced against those other groups
. So in my example, Judaism idea would be
um if you looked across a whole bunch of different
people and you measured whether they think there's like a
genetic basis of being Jewish, though the person,
people who more think there is are gonna be more
anti Semitic than the people who less think there is
. The second thing we found is that if you
change people's essentialism, like for example, we make
people more essentialist or make them less essentialist that has
no effect at all on how prejudiced they are.
So what those two things together seem to suggest is
that the causal arrow is going the other way.
So if you think about, I don't know,
Hitler was very anti Semitic and also thought there was
like this essential, essential aspect of Judi. So
what I say you could think is just for whatever
reason she just happened to think there's like this,
um, heritable genetic thing and then that caused him
to be anti Semitic. But maybe it's the other
way, it's that for whatever reason, he hated
this group of people and then he hitting this group
of people led him to think this weird stuff.
Like, so then if we could somehow make him
stop believing all of that weird stuff, like about
heritability or something, it, it wouldn't make him
be less an anti Semitic. It's only, it's
the other way. If we could make him less
anti-semitic, then it would make him less involved in
this weird stuff. So this one thing seemed to
suggest it's really going the other way. It's not
that people's scientific beliefs are having these downstream impacts on
their moral judgments. It's that people's moral judgments are
having these downstream impacts on their scientific beliefs. That
, that's, that's really fascinating. So, uh
I mean, uh yeah, because we tend to
have this idea that if people are essentialist, then
that cause that causes their uh beliefs, their discriminatory
or hateful be beliefs. But then what you're saying
there is that it could be the other way around
that people already have those beliefs and then uh that
would cause them to be essentially sort, we centralize
certain groups of people. Yeah, that's the result
we're getting, we very much expected it to be
the other way, the way that you said.
But I don't confirm what we thought, like,
it really feels like. Yeah, if, if
we took some very racist people and all we did
was say, um, you know, here's some
interesting results about genetics or something like that and then
suppose that they were very convinced they were like,
oh, yeah, I really appreciate all this genetic
information. Sound. That sounds totally right. That
wouldn't make them less racist. It's just, it's
, it's like, that's not the thing that would
actually change the, the degree to which they're doing
racist things. Yeah, that's very interesting. So
, uh I have a couple of more questions uh
now regarding how people understand truth itself, so does
the way people interact socially? I mean, if
they are cooperating or competing, more influence how they
comes through truth in terms of subjectivity or objectivity.
Yeah, this really relates to the topic we were
talking about a really long time ago, we were
talking about whether people think there even is an objective
, the right answer to a question. So in
these studies with Matthew Fisher, we had participants randomly
assigned to two groups. So in one group,
they were told, OK, you're gonna talk with
someone who has the opposite opinion of you on some
, on this topic. So um for example,
if you're pro choice, this other person will be
pro-life or if you're in favor of the death penalty
, this other person will be opposed to the death
penalty. And then, and they really are talking
, they really are engaged in this discussion with this
other person. They're doing it on the internet,
like through this kind of chat service. And then
in one group we said, um, so what
you have to do is like, win the argument
. Like, um this other person is gonna argue
, say for the pro life position, you have
to like beat them and, and win for the
um pro choice position. But in the other condition
, he said, um this other person has the
opposite view of you. And we want you to
like, try to understand this other person and for
you and this other person to kind of corporate to
each understand where the other one is coming from.
Like why do they think the things they do?
Like what's their perspective and so forth? So then
participants um are just like having a conversation where they're
like writing back and forth to each other in this
way, either to defeat the other or to um
understand the other. And then after silver, then
we ask the kind of question we talked about earlier
, is there really a truth about this question?
So say about the abortion question, is there really
a right answer between pro life and portraits? And
what we find is that the more you're in a
competitive interaction where you're trying to like defeat the other
person, the more you think there is an objective
answer. And when you're in a co-operative interaction.
We're trying to understand the other person, the more
you think there isn't even a correct. And so
with that in mind, uh my last question will
be then can politics and specifically political polarization change our
understanding of truth? That's a great question. I
, I don't know the answer to your question,
but I'm even though I don't know, I'm just
gonna make a, make a guess. So,
um right now, what we find is that um
uh well, there's a correlation that the, the
more people are divided about some question, the more
people think there's no objectively right answer to it.
So, um if you ask, is there a
right answer about whether murder is morally wrong? People
think there is, if you ask is the right
answer about whether abortion is morally wrong. People tend
to think that there's not. And then, although
we don't have any data to suggest this, my
guess is that that effect arises because people are able
to think about people on the opposite side of this
issue in a certain way, they're able to like
kind of take the perspective of the that person and
care about that person and so forth. But if
polarization continues to grow, so that we're really forming
almost like two nations where people never interact with each
other and never talk with each other. They don't
even care whether the other person likes them and they're
just each talking with people on their own side of
the aisle and not connecting with people. Not yet
. My guess would be that it will gradually change
. And this tendency that we see right now,
if people say maybe that person isn't actually wrong,
maybe there's no truth of the matter that will decrease
and then people will start to see there's only one
truth and it's our truth. We're the ones who
are right and most people are. Ok, great
. So, uh Josh, just before we go
, would you like to tell people where they can
find you and your work on the internet? Oh
, I don't know. I mean, uh wait
, that's a great question. You, I guess
maybe you, I mean, you could just go
to my website but that might not be much fun
. Maybe a fun thing to do would be if
you look up experimental philosophy on, on youtube,
you can find uh videos of that are explaining different
experimental philosophy studies and that's sort of where people are
acting out these little stories that I just told you
and that might be much more enjoyable. OK,
great. So, thank you so much for taking
the time to come on the show. It's been
real fun to talk to you. Thank you so
much. I really appreciate this. Hi guys.
Thank you for watching this interview until the end.
If you liked it, please do not forget to
like it, share, comment and subscribe and if
you like more generally what I'm doing, please consider
supporting the show on Patreon or paypal. You have
all of the links in the description of this interview
. The show is brought to you by En Lights
learning and development. Done differently. Check their website
at alights.com. I would also like to give a
huge thank you to my main patrons and paypal supporters
per Larson Jerry Mueller and Frederick Sunda Bernards, all
of election and Weser, Adam Castle Matthew Whitting Whitting
Bear. No wolf, Tim Hollis, Eric,
Alania John Connors, Philip Forst Connelly, Robert Winde
Ruin. Nai Zoup, Mark Nevs Colin Hall,
Simon Columbus, Phil, Kavana, Michael Stormer,
Samuel Andrea Francis for the AGD Alexander Dan Bauer,
Fergal, Ken Hall, Herzog Michel, Jonathan Lit
Jars and the Samuel Correa, Eric Heins, Mark
Smith, Jan We Amal S Franz, David Sloan
Wilson, Ya De Roma Roach, Jan Punter,
Romani Charlotte, Bli Nicole. Bear, Adam and
Pao Assy Naw Guy Madison Gary G Hallman, Samo
Zal Arien Y, Nick Golden Paul Talent in John
Bar was Julian Price Edward Hall Eden Bronner, Douglas
Fry Franca Beto Lotti Gabriel Pan Cortez, Lelis Scott
Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sonny Smith, John
Wiesman, Martin Ackland, Daniel Friedman, William Buckner
, Paul George Arnold Luke Lo A George the off
Chris Williamson, Peter Lawson, David Williams the Costa
, Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Shaw and Murray
Martinez Le Chevalier bangalore atheists, Larry Daley Junior Holt
Eric B. Starry Michael Bailey then Sperber, Robert
Grassy Rough the RP MD. Ior Jeff mcmahon,
Jake Zul Barnabas, Radix, Mark Campbell, Richard
Bowen Thomas, the Dauber Luke Ne and Chris story
Manuel Oliveira, Kimberly Johnson and Benjamin Gilbert. A
special thanks to my producers, these our web gem
Frank Luca, Tom Weam Bernard Ni Ortiz Dixon,
Benedict Mueller Vege, Gli Thomas Trumble, Catherine and
Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Robert Lewis and
Al Nick Ortiz. And to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Si Adrian and Bogdan Kut. Thank
you for all.